[Music]
what's the Middle top uh so I just put
music concerts just in general cuz I
realized thinking back to this year I
went to a fuckload of music concerts I
think I saw about 15 bands this year
holy [__] um two two Festival can't
believe you missed the Geeks plus
Christmas party because of another
[__] concert dude I had to go see
excuse me exuse dude I had to see TK
live and he was [__] insane you know
he's almost 50 is the guy who did the is
it the guy did the yeah did do unravel
no he didn't what no I would ask for a
refund no because I'd like his band I
don't well [__] you I'm there for the
song I I went there for the band I'm
there for the beams I'm kidding no he
didn't do any like solo stuff but like
it's actually cuz like I've been
following this band like for a really
really long time because my cousin
actually used to be one of the
photographers when there was still like
an indie band up inom so like I'd known
about them for a really long time and
then when I saw that they did the
psychopath opening I was just like oh oh
[__] that's my band right there yo like
it's I was having a real hipster moment
but then I think our coffees are here
right might be
upstairs yeah they were like quite a
while ago right sorry to interrupt
that's okay uh but yeah so like going to
see dinto was like big big uh you know
bucket list band that I wanted to go see
absolutely [__] insane I don't know
how TK can scream like that live and not
burst his [__] L how long is he
singing for about an hour and a half
[__] offet yeah and he was going [__]
ham and it was really funny because the
basist is like uh this girl called meal
and she's this tiny tiny [__]
Japanese woman it makes her bass look
like a [__] double base and uh and
like in the middle they had like a
little uh I guess uh you know just MC
moment where they would just like kind
of talk to the crowd and I guess they
were selling merch and I guess they do
all their merch themselves because
they're still kind of a smaller band and
Mio I I I swear like Mio leg might have
been like the model for Boi cuz that's
how she kind of was like on stage she
was this really [__] quiet timid girl
and she's just like we have
shirts and a hat is this a a thing in
Japanese concerts cuz I've only been to
one but they like stopped the show
halfway to do like a merch presentation
yeah I think it's a Japanese thing it's
like like wait what cuz I I've seen that
quite a bit it's also a Japanese thing
where they have to like every song has
to have like an anecdote to go with that
song yeah you know what I mean it's like
that [__] Taylor Swift like every
time she introduces a new song there has
to be some kind of [__] story
attached to it yeah yeah uh no but SEC
actually didn't do that much of that um
but yeah like I I think I knocked off
quite a bit of like bucket list bands
this year like I saw Maxim in the
hormone which were [__] insane I saw
baby metal which were [__] insane
Bring Me The Horizon Simple Plan like
ton of what been the best con you've
been to this year then oh that's hard
did bring me to the rise and sing the
gigachad song they did they did [__]
yeah do the Giga so they did did they
talk about the gig they didn't talk
about it but it was very obvious like
cuz the moment it came on all the
foreigners were
like
song you know the first song they played
oh yeah they opened up with that which
is [__] awesome but I'd say I I I'd
have to say probably the best one was
surprisingly baby metal oh [__] cuz like
we were they were at they were at this
like metal festival we went so the Bring
Me The Horizon festival and like a ton
of like you know obviously big metal
bands like bring me and like Max the
hormone but there were also some like
really small Japanese bands as well that
were there which was kind of cool for
bring me to like include and like kind
of show off cuz like I looked up some of
these bands and they were they had like
800 monthly listeners on Spotify or
something there tiny tiny bands find
these guys I don't know because like all
the bands they invited thank you all the
bands they invited uh like Ollie from
Bring Me The Horizon were like personal
fans of them and they wanted to invite
them out so I'm like that was really
cool like notion of them but baby metal
it was was like I've never seen that
wholesome of a mosh pit happen before
cuz when they played gimme chocolate
which is like you know their big song
and a Circle of Death started happening
normally in like a metal concer Circle
of Death you know people are like
throwing punches like you know [__]
pushing people around like it's called a
circle of death for a reason but the
bring me but the give me chocolate
Circle of Death everyone was just
running around high-fiving everyone and
I was like
y wait why why would I want to get
beaten up because it's a metal coner I
don't want to get beaten
that's what happens in a metal coner
moshit man what the heck a high five
Circle of Death it was really funny all
these like like a slice of life version
all these Japanese dudes just [__]
going yay to everyone outside the circle
de sounds like sounds like what would
happen in a Kon concert yeah legit it
was like a Kon concert but yeah uh so
that's why I just included all music
concerts cuz I [__] L my experience
so if I'm seen this correctly Joey yeah
you've finally started Hunter Hunter is
that manga or anime manga okay so I've
I've caught up to the Monger of Hunter
Hunter uh I finally sat down I thought
you know what caught up caught up we
spoke about this in the previous episode
yeah we've talked about it you read the
boat po I've read The Boat
Part you just hurry the [__] up I know I
I get it now yeah it's like and I wish I
didn't because now I'm sitting there
being like great another show I have to
wait for I it's like it's the the hunt
onto [__] has reached a point where I'm
like this is a joke now you're you're
actively trying to like just never
finish this
so what's what's your favorite Arc yeah
probably cim ant C
ant I think the cim ant Arc is is gets
way too much hate I think it's that's
what I didn't understand why is cim ant
now that I know the full concept because
it's so long and Anime only fans watch
it and it's like 80 episodes out of the
140 odd so it's it's most of it and I
think most people who who know of hun
Hunter have only watched the anime and I
and I can understand why they' think hey
this is really [__] long I mean it
was long in the manga as well but it
also [__] high for I I think chimra
ant has some of the best peaks of Hunter
Hunter oh totally I I feel anime flat
out yeah paks of anime flat out I think
my favorite Arc of Hunter Hunter is pro
oh this is so hard Greed Island I really
[__] like Greed Island GRE Island
Greed Island isn't that like a really
unpopular one that's a really unpopular
one uh I really the people who like it
really like it I've noticed the thing I
loved about GRE do it's not my favorite
do I think York is my favorite Arc uh
just because like that Arc is so dense
where it's rare that you see an arc
where every episode you're like holy
[__] that was a banger you put on the
next episode you're like holy [__] this
was also a banger and it just keeps
delivering every single one thing I
didn't like about the auctioneering arc
it was just it's it's a bit of a nitpick
but like I just didn't like in I don't
know how it is in the anime but in the
manga there's like three or four maybe
five chapters back to back where gone
and KD are learning to like the ins and
outs of like auctioning and I'm just
like am I reading a manga or am I
reading a textbook about auctioning like
I get like you want to like teach me
this stuff toi but like I just want you
to get to the auction sometimes you turn
the the page in Hunter Hunter and you're
just greeted with a novel and you're
like you're like why did you bother
drawing I remember in the GRE why even
bother in Greed Island when they're
first like introducing the card system
in the manga there's like six pages
where Togashi just shows all the cards
that in Greed Island with like all the
text and [__] and it's like and then by
the end of Greed Island I realized I'm
like I think about 80% of these cars
just never showed up yeah the thing I've
really liked which cool I guess the
thing I really liked about Greed Island
is that that was the arc that convinced
me that nen is just the best power
system just the fact that you can create
an entire world out of this malleable
system I was like holy [__] this is
insane of course yes maybe it's a bit
self-indulgent I don't kind of give I
kind of don't give a [__] just because
of how interesting and how in-depth this
power system is that this AR kind of
like displayed the depth and the limits
of what you could do with something like
this also not to give spoilers but like
I'd kind of like already slightly heard
about like what happens to like midm
yeah but when I got to the manga like
the b in the manga I still
cried so that death is he crazy is one
of the best villains in anime manga
period such a good villain for that Arc
especially so yeah I finally see the
hype now I get it I knew I was going to
like it as I've been saying but now I
actually know the full context I have to
watch for Metal Alchemist you probably
watch hunter hunter or red Hunter Hunter
yeah um octopath traveler too yeah you
liked it that much I thought this was
[__] amazing and especially coming
from the fact that I also played
octopath traveler 1 I realized just how
much of a like just a missed opportunity
octopath travel one was because like in
in terms of the actual gameplay it's not
that much different to octopath travel
one um like to explain octopath travel
for anyone who doesn't know basically
it's a jrpg uh square unques but you
follow eight protagonists and all of
their stories all at the same time yeah
um and as you go through the world you
unlock different parts of the story of
each of the characters and then it gets
to a final ending octo paath octo paath
exactly but octopath traveler 2 I think
for one like the music is [__] god
tier like I think I'm actually going to
try and go to the concert next year that
they have and also the stories and
characters were just infinitely more
interesting than the first one cuz I
think that was the biggest struggle with
me finishing octopath traveler 1 was
that like I wasn't invested in every
single character whereas which made it
difficult when you trying to go through
the story elements of every single
character but with octop traveler 2
every character I was like Banger Banger
Banger every single story line was just
so engaging and the ending as well is
just like it's hard as [__] like I had
to grind the [__] out of for the end but
it was a really really just like
satisfying I think I put in about 100
hours into this one but it was such a
good game and I think it's like kind of
slept on just because I feel a lot of
people were kind of just thrown off from
playing octopath traveler 1 but so if
you didn't like octopath travel one for
those reasons I would highly recommend
youel was this one that was badly
reviewed or was it the first one first
one okay yeah the second one actually I
think is like all like critically
acclaimed like everybody agrees that
compared to one two is like infinitely
better it's always better when the first
one's better than the second cuz it's
easier to to sell people on the it's
kind of sad to be like hey play an 80
hour game for the next one that's good
yeah well luckily you don't have to play
one to play two yeah but everyone says
that a lot of the time and it's
sometimes it's like but I but I feel
like I should no I think that with two
there was literally no connection at all
the only connection is that it's the
same type of gameplay but in terms of
characters and story it's all different
uh so yeah freaking great also like so
many like really really high profile
anime voice actors are in the Japanese
version of this like it's crazy like
hiu like all these like huge names I'm
just like oh I recognize that voice I
recognize that voice I recognize that
voice so yeah really really solid I'd
say it's probably my favorite J better
about this compared to number one I
think it just made the stories a little
more coherent because the way you play
octopath you're obviously not going to
follow the chapter of one character
simultaneously like cease one part of
the story of a character and then you're
going to move on to another part of a
different character story so octopath
traveler 1 the way they wrote each of
the story lines kind of made it a little
bit difficult to like remind yourself
like oh yeah where was I in the story
with this particular character again cuz
I was busy doing three other character
stories whereas with two they made the
story a lot more streamlined so that it
just made sense especially with like the
progression in the game it just felt
more cohesive in general and the music
and the visuals they just like up that
as well so it's yeah really really solid
jrpg okay uh hell's Paradise hell's
Paradise this is your only anime I had
to put an anime on there is this is this
the anime version this is the anime
version you had to put an anime on there
you didn't you didn't have to put an
anime come on fact that it's hell's
Paradise I'm like look I like this is
this is like my favorite eight out of 10
show of the year I great time but like
not a masterpiece I think that's why I
put it on there because I just had a
really fun time watching time n like I'm
not going to say it's like a 10 out of
10 Masterpiece or anything but like just
it was just nice to see like a no
[__] No Frills shown in I I I knew
it was going to be an extremely solid
show after episode one and I didn't
think it was going to be it was going to
go to like some crazy like plot twist
depths or anything like that but I just
knew it was going to be a fun time I
just like the fact that there was just
like almost zero filler to it which is
always nice you know because it's like
one when Once one thing happens like
boom here comes the next thing here
comes the next thing and I'm like oh
okay I'm actually like engaged now you
think you're going to watch season two
yeah probably I I mean I've also read
ahead on the manga as well I'm not going
to lie it start like I really liked the
beginning of Hell's Paradise I love the
it was basically what gave me what the
Dark Continent in Hunter Hunter hasn't
given yet the sense of Doom the sense of
Doom exploration anything can [__] you
up MH and then the power system got
introduced and I'm like ah okay this is
this is kind of it just turns it's kind
of starting to feel like it's turning
into like a more traditional generic
shown in and I'm like oh I don't know if
it's interesting enough to keep my
attention if the anime only or Manga
this is the anime only so you you know
you know the end of the anime where they
introduced that they started introducing
that power system and then of course all
the protagonists master it in like a day
Y and I'm like and I'm like okay uh I
just [__] with that guy who chopped his
arm off I just like that guy he's fun oh
yeah he's just fun to watch yeah I mean
that's the thing Samurai guy yeah yeah
all the side characters are just so
likable and just so insane and it's like
again like you know I definitely have
like qualms with it for sure but I just
had a really enjoyable time watching I
think hottest anime character of the
year was
Yuzu the uh the uh samurai samurai girl
other the ninja girl yeah dude she on my
knees I I pretty damn hot when I look
back of the year's hottest characters
I'm like
yeah I was like when they gave her the
power to what was it
cre sweat or some [__] like that I'm
like I'm like oh god oh they know what
they doing it reminds me of that Meme
with the like the guy on like a Tik Tok
holding a cigar in a suit I don't know
why it's just just like me and the boys
getting ready to appreciate it's like oh
gosh definitely for sure yeah so I think
like out of all the ones like I think
for me this is like how many anime did
you watch this year out of curiosity oh
I wish I I should start keeping track
I'm not going to but yeah I should keep
track I'd say maybe about 10 10 oh [__]
yeah I've watched a decent amount like
just the ones that I think I'm going to
get into or that interests me like I'm
not going to watch all the [__] isak
like [__] that but like yeah I think
just out of all the ones I watch like
this one I just was like yeah hell yeah
you know it kind of reminded it kind of
took me back to like that time where
like I could just turn my brain off and
watch a nice show what about uh nonsense
I me nonsense is pretty self-expand yeah
I mean I put nonsense there but like
just congratulations on your thank you
Cy Punk launch by thank you very much uh
like the I'm just mostly talking about
just like Japanese street wear in this
case because it's not just the nonsense
you put yourself
to if I'm going to sell out to anyone
I'm going to sell out to myself but uh
yeah just like obviously from doing the
nonsense stuff hardcore this year I just
got more into like the different sects
of like Japanese fashion and like
Japanese Street Weare stuff so like yeah
just in general I've just yeah got into
clothing a lot more which I think just
makes sense
by the way the stuff is still available
I would hope you have you would have got
into clothing a lot more considering you
now own a clothing company Joey would
have been pretty worrying I'll take the
whole collection please thank you Joe
than you yeah still Pokémon go yeah what
the [__]
is3 poon go to the this is this is you
reaching to the bottom of the Bargain
Bin this guy will literally do anything
but watch anime I like what else did I
do this year oh God Pokémon go okay okay
okay with this one right I saw this
[__] video of you playing a 4 400 Day
game What's going oning why why AR you
why are you not watching anime come on
[Music]
cuz cuz nothing good came out 2023
right just kidding but yeah okay with
Pokémon go uh because we did so much
[__] traveling this year like more
than at least I did anyway I don't know
about you guys but we I think all three
of us we did a lot of traveling what you
talking about I was there with it for
most of you yeah but I mean also went to
a lot of places myself in the same place
Joey yeah but like I think because you
know I went traveling so freaking much
and you know uh my friend like recently
got back into Pokémon go like earlier
this year uh and I saw him playing it
and I was like oh has like anything new
change at all cuz I hav played the game
since like basically the beginning of Co
when like you couldn't go outside uh and
he was like oh yeah and he showed me all
the new stuff that they had and I was
like oh wow this is actually like a
playable game again so I picked it up
and it was great because during the
travels you can get like region
exclusive [__] so I was like well it
makes sense I guess while I'm traveling
I might as well have something to do so
I picked up Pokémon go again and uh it's
actually a really [__] fun game again
cuz before like they at they just
basically were like the vanilla version
of this game was just like go out into
the world walk around catch Pokémon
complete your decks blah blah blah but
now they've added like you know uh
rocket grunts they've added raids
they've added uh [__] [__] what else
like Bas like a ton of new [__] that
actually makes it so that you don't have
to go outside all the time to like still
interact with the game yeah and it just
made sense for me considering that again
I traveled so much I was like well I'm
going to get all the exclusive [__]
it'll be fun again and now that they've
added like pretty much up to the latest
generation there's like over a thousand
Pokémon now you can catch so there's
just more longevity in the game as well
so yeah that's uh that's what I got into
this year I guess uh that's about
it I am I am a pretty varied list I am a
child is what we figured out yes well
good to know that you're rediscovering
your inner 13-year-old y as we all are
as I'm approaching 30 I'm like God damn
I want to go back take me back take me
back take me back
please all right shall we move on to the
next one then who's next you want to go
next Corner sure yeah I'll go next mine
yet